♪ [music] ♪
As we build up towards discounted cash
flow valuations, we've talked about the
first two inputs that drive value,
cash flows and discount rates, in the
last session. This session,
we talk about that estimate that makes
most of us uncomfortable,
which is future growth.
So let's talk about estimating the growth
and cash flows for a company.
Now, if you look at most valuations and
you look at where the growth rate in these
valuations comes from,
it comes from one of two sources.
One is historical growth.
Many analysts when they value companies
look at the past. So if your company has
grown 30% in the last 5 years,
they project that as the growth rate for
the next 5 years or the next 10 years.
There's nothing wrong with that but there
are a couple of things you might want
to keep in mind. The first is,
historically, past growth has not been a
very good predictor of future growth.
You often see companies go from high
growth rates to low growth rates
overnight. The second is
scaling up is hard to do.
Let me explain what I mean.
If you take a small company and you look
at its history, it might have been able
to grow at 75% a year for the last five
years, but remember, in the process,
it's become a much bigger company.
Even if the characteristics of the company
have not changed, the growth rate in the
future is likely to be lower.
So look at past growth,
but don't let it be the driving force
for your future growth.
The second way in which people get growth
rates in valuation is they look at outside
estimates. If you're an investor valuing
a U.S. company, for instance,
it is easy to get an expected growth
in earnings for your company based on what
analysts following this company
are projecting for this company.
It's called a consensus growth rate.
You're saying, "What's wrong with that?
After all, those analysts know a lot more
about this company than you do." Well,
that might be true, but if you use
an analyst's estimate of growth,
you've turned over your valuation,
the most critical input, to someone else.
Analysts are not that good at forecasting
long-term growth. They're very good at
forecasting short-term growth,
growth in the next quarter,
but that's not what should drive
your valuation. So again,
if you're valuing a company,
look at what analysts are projecting as
growth, but don't let that become your
growth rate just because you trust them to
do a good job. The second way you can get
an outside estimate of growth is to ask
managers of a company what the expected
growth in the company is going to be. Now,
it's true. Managers know a lot more
about the company than you and I do.
But it's also true that managers cannot
be objective. After all,
it's their company. So my caution
with outside estimates of growth is,
by using them, we're turning over the most
critical input in valuation to somebody
else, and in the process,
it's easy to lose control of your
valuation. So at this point,
you're probably in the uncomfortable spot
of saying, "How am I going to estimate
growth if I don't use past growth and I
don't ask other people what the growth
rate is going to be?"
There's a third way of estimating growth
that I call a fundamental growth rate.
And here's what drives the growth
of a company. The growth of a company is
not something that you and I can come
up with or endow the company with.
It's got to be earned.
And here's what I mean about growth being
earned. For a company to grow,
it has to reinvest and reinvest well at
the same time. In fact, algebraically,
the growth in earnings for a company is a
product of how much you reinvest and how
well you reinvest. Now,
depending on whether you're doing
an equity valuation or valuing an entire
business, the way you measure how much you
reinvest and how well you reinvest is
going to be different.
Let's start with equity earnings.
If your focus is on equity earnings,
you're going to measure how much you
reinvest with the retention ratio.
In the retention ratio,
you look at the proportion of your net
income that you put back into the business
and you measure how well you reinvest
with the return in equity,
that's net income as a function of the
book value of equity invested in a
project. So if you have a 60% retention
ratio and a 30% return on equity,
your expected growth in equity earnings is
going to be 18%. Now,
if you're focusing on operating income,
your definitions of reinvestment and
returns have to be different.
The reinvestment rate, then,
will be the percentage of your after-tax
operating income that you put back in the
business in the form of net CapEx and
change in working capital.
So if you take the net CapEx,
CapEx minus depreciation, the change in
working capital as a percentage of your
after-tax operating income,
that tells you how much of your after-tax
operating income goes back into the
business. And you measure how well
you reinvest, not with the return on
equity but with the return
on invested capital.
You look at after-tax operating income
as a percentage of the total capital,
not just the book equity,
but the book equity plus the book debt
minus cash invested in the project.
Retention ratio times return on capital is
expected growth in operating income.
The advantage of a fundamental growth
approach to estimating growth is,
when you want to increase growth,
I'm going to hold you accountable.
Accountable in what sense?
I'm going to ask you,
"Where is that increase in growth coming
from? Is it coming from the company
reinvesting more, which will mean less
cash flows up front?
Or is it coming from better investment?"
In which case, you have to tell me where
those better investments are coming from.
It makes you think about the drivers
of growth. So let's take a simple example,
Deutsche, in 2008, to illustrate how this
process have worked. In 2008,
Deutsche had a return in equity of 19.45%.
Its retention ratio was about 67%.
Put differently, it held back 67% of its
net income to put back into the business
and was making roughly 19.45% as a return
on equity in that investment.
If we assume that Deutsche can maintain
those numbers, because those are the
numbers from the most recent year,
Deutsche's expected growth rate will be
about 13.04%. That's at the retention
ratio times return on equity.
It's as simple as that.
Now, you're saying, "Why assume that it
can maintain those numbers? Well, 2007,
the most recent year that I had data for,
when I valued Deutsche in 2008,
was a very good year for Deutsche.
You could actually argue that, over time,
those numbers would be difficult to
maintain and you could replace the actual
return on equity in 2007 with a normalized
number. The way I normalized this number
was I looked at the average return on
equity between 2003 and 2007.
And that number was lower, 11.81%.
I also looked at the average retention
ratio between 2003 and 2007,
and that number was also lower, 46%.
You take those normalized numbers,
the product of those normalized numbers
gives me an expected growth rate of 5.4%.
Now, if I were valuing Deutsche in 2008,
I would argue that that 5.4% is a much
better estimate of growth than just using
the last year, using historical growth,
or using an analyst projection of growth.
It's a number that's based on discipline.
Discipline in what sense?
It ties your growth to what the company
does. So as you look at your company,
here's what I'd like you to start thinking
about. Look up the historical growth
on your company or estimate it yourself.
Look up what others are estimating
as growth for the company,
but that shouldn't be your end game.
Then focus in on fundamentals.
Look at how much of your earnings the
company reinvested back into the business
last year and how well it's
reinvesting money. Those will become the
foundation for your estimation
of future growth.
♪ [music] ♪